My name is Henry Miloa. Allow me to
speak.
>> Hello, my name is Henry Miloa. My
profession is mechanical engineering,
but I have only three questions.
My first question,
>> can you can you just repeat
>> your name?
>> My name is Henry Milo.
>> His name is Henry Miloa. He has three
Henry.
>> Henry. Henry.
>> Yes. He has three question to ask.
>> Okay. Yes, brother Henry, you're most
welcome.
>> My first question is
that is two books concerning the living
God.
>> Hello
>> and Bible.
These two books
which one
which one is the first published book
among in the world?
My second question,
>> I'll ask the first I'll reply to the
first question. The brother asked that
there are two books, the Quran and the
Bible. Which book was published first?
>> Uh was published first among the people.
>> Yes. Among the two what we believe that
Isaam prophet Jesus he got the vah
called as injil the gospel. We believe
that gospel was revealed to prophet
Jesus peace be upon him. The present
book that you have the Bible is a
mixture. It is not the original
in that was revealed to prophet Jesus.
The original that was revealed to
prophet Jesus we believe is the word of
God. But the present Bible that you have
was written many years after Jesus
Christ peace be upon him. 70 years after
later on written by human beings. So the
present bible comes from the Greek word
biblo meaning book of books
and it's a mixture of the word of god
word of prophet word of historian and
also pornography
between the two the Quran was revealed
to prophet Muhammad peace be upon him.
The glorious Quran is the last and final
revelation of almighty god revealed to
the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. And Allah
says in surah hijra chapter 15 verse
number 9, we have revealed the Quran and
we shall guard it from corruption. So
this Quran is the pure word of God. If I
give you a glass of water which is pure,
will you drink it?
Pure water, will you drink it?
>> What?
>> If I give you a glass of water which is
pure, will you drink it?
>> No. No. No.
>> Yes. I can't drink. I can't drink.
>> Pure water. Yes. But if in that water I
add in front of you a drop from the
gutter dirty water and mix it then will
you drink it? No no no it because it's
adulterated even if you mix it you may
not be able to see it. If one drop of
gutter water in a glass of water if you
mix it it will dissolve. But the moment
you know there is adulteration you won't
drink it. Similarly the glorious Quran
is a pure word of God. The Bible is a
mixture. So between the two the better
book and the latest book and the correct
book that human beings should follow is
the Quran because Bible in g was only
sent for a particular group of people.
It's not supposed to be followed till
eternity. Bible is supposed to be
followed Quran is supposed to be
followed till eternity by the whole of
humankind. So today all the human beings
in the world whether in America, in
Europe, in Africa, in India, in Pakistan
should follow the Quran
and then you will get salvation.
>> Your next question, second question is
this.
There is a
there is a learning in the Bible calling
uh we are being we are being we are
being taught that is a baptism
for forgiveness of our sin for our
inheritance sin from Adam
but this we got it in the Bible only his
Quran also teach about the baptism
>> brother he's asking a question about
baptism in Bible. They have been taught
about baptism in their Bible. His
question is, is there baptism in Quran?
>> Yeah.
>> The brothers asked a question in the
Bible, we have baptism. Is there any
baptism in Quran? Quran says that no one
better to baptize than Allah. In
religion of Islam, we don't believe in
baptism.
We don't have to take a dip in the
water.
We don't require the Holy Ghost. In
Islam, you only say with your lips that
there is one God and Prophet Muhammad is
a messenger, you become a Muslim.
There's no require of taking dip and
baptizing in in Islam.
>> Can we have the last question?
>> Okay, I understand that. But my the last
question is why Jesus was baptized?
>> Yeah.
>> Was
>> why Jesus was baptized?
Brother's question is why was Jesus
baptized?
>> Brother asking why was Jesus baptized?
That is as per the Bible not as per the
Quran. As for the Quran not required as
per Bible he was baptized. As per the
Bible in Islam we don't require baptism.
That is what the Bible says. Therefore,
I told you Bible is a mixture of the
word of God, of the word of prophet, of
the word of historians, of pornography.
We believe that every child is born
sinless.
Every child, whether born in Africa,
whether born in America, whether born in
Europe, he's born sinless.
We don't believe that they were born
with sin. There's no requirement of
baptizing in Islam.
And we believe that every child is born
in sin.
Hope that answers the question.
>> Thank you.
>> Uh thank you,
>> brother. Do you believe there is one
God?
>> Yes, I know.
>> Do you believe Jesus is God or Jesus is
a messenger of God?
>> I know.
>> Jesus is a messenger of God.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Do you believe that Prophet
Muhammad is a messenger of God?
>> Yes.
>> Very good. Then you're a Muslim. There
are two things required for anyone to
become a Muslim. Number one, believe
that there's one God and believe that
Prophet Muhammad is a messenger.
>> And you agree with both. Do would you
like to say it in Arabic?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, I'll say it and you can repeat it.
Yeah. Ashu
Ashah Allah allahill
>> Abdu
>> Abdul
>> I bear witness
>> that
>> there is no God
>> but Allah
>> and I bear witness witness.
>> And I bear witness
>> that Prophet Muhammad
>> is the messenger
>> and servant
>> of Allah
>> of Allah.
>> MASHALLAH.
>> MASHALLAH. BROTHER, welcome to the fold
of Islam and all your previous sins have
been forgiven. I request you to read the
translation of the Quran. I request to
you all the brothers, all the four
brothers that have accepted Islam, I
request them to be in touch with the
Islamic organization in Mombasa so that
you get more information regarding
Islam. And I pray that you convey the
message to your family members, to your
friends, and get them too close to the
Islam.